I'm here with Wesley so the hero of the
tournament and the leader of the
tournament right now yes Wesley
congratulations first decisive result we
have when you managed to win the game it
all started with Queen indan when you
saw it on the board did you sorry King
indan not Queen
Gambit well were you happy to see it on
the board when Rich decided to go for it
yeah first of all I'm very pleased with
the win I mean feels like a decade since
I last won a game yeah like so I want to
say glory to to Christ for for that
because all WIS come from him and uh
yeah yeah it's a good feeling yeah yeah
for sure I I mean I you know I mean I
think the world is getting crazy
nowadays with war and sickness
everywhere so I'm kind of actually not
100% Focus or chess even in this
tournament because I'm like following
all the news about Russia Ukraine also
by ISL but I'm glad I can still win a
game
like and Richard is a great opponent I
said earlier he's a great player two
years ago in the singfield cup he played
really well I think one of his best
tournaments or he was fighting for first
place up to the very last round I
believe so um um yeah it's nice to to
finally win a game he's also very
creative player yes and probably today
just wanted to show that he's ready for
fight yeah I
was going to say I didn't really prepare
actually at all for today cuz yesterday
was Thanksgiving yes exactly we had a
dinner and I think you were at the table
sitting together with Richard with
Richard yeah I'm I mean I'm in very good
terms with Richard and his wife joavan I
see them a lot also we in Europe we
played the tournament recently in Berlin
a blitz tournament and uh we're in
really good terms terms I mean think
he's a he's a great guy he's got a great
wife so uh uh yeah but uh recently I
think he's been playing also nonstop
like he played isop man and then he
played in the European team so I don't
know how he just traveled all this way
is here 25 hours yeah I don't know how
players like him or others or Fabby Fab
has played non-stop for two months I
don't know how they do it but for me I I
kind of need like a two we break after
every major tournament just to re
regenerate but uh you know F but they're
doing it so um yeah I was very surprised
by the king's engan like I said I didn't
prepare at all so I just thought I'd
play one C4 see what happens I actually
haven't played 1 C4 in quite a bit in
classical game so he spent over two
minutes here thinking like of course
black has many good replies I thought he
would go for like Bishop B4 stuff or
something like that like E5 is
incredibly solid but by thought for w
went for the king's Indian like I didn't
expect the Kings Indian because it takes
a lot of courage to play it in a
classical game uh and so shout out to
him
but I decided just if he was going to
play Kings and I'll play the samish
because I like I've been playing Knight
F3 and Bishop E2 like ala and I had a
big Blitz match on on the Kings indan
just a couple months back online so I
was getting much better positions but he
was he kept beating me every game so I
said okay like let's change this
something yeah so I thought I'd play F3
and also it's more solid because you you
still you have options to Castle Queen
side so in the worst case I won't get
checkmated on the king side hopefully
but I haven't played the samish in like
seven years I believe or something like
that and then yeah I thought C5 was the
best but I didn't know exactly what
Richard was going to play like I think
C5 is very very solid now after Bishop
E3 Knight C6 or I think Maxim play C5
here watch here like D5 E6 and you know
white is not better but it's just very
complex I play Bishop D7 quickly and I
figured he's probably prepared against
the main lines with Knight C1 or Rook
C1 so played Rook B1 actually shout out
to my boy and
Tang because uh I was working with him
actually N9 years ago mhm back in
2014 and uh Rook B1 was his idea I
remember very clear clearly but
something what you just analyzed n years
to your mind yeah well actually he
showed it to me I I don't think he
remembered it now like I don't think he
even remembers how
to about that session but I think Rook
B8 like usually Rook C1 is the move but
I think he played Rook B1 against me but
think is much more effective against
Rook B8 because like here for example
The Rook is passive on the B8 but when
Play Bishop D7 I thought I'll play Rook
B1 anyway just to surprise
Richie but I think H5
I think he still prepared this it looks
so ugly okay I don't know if H5 is his
preparation he just he SP it quickly yes
yeah he probably spent like 6 minutes
mhm something like that but uh it looks
very ugly but uh I couldn't it's like it
gives you all this time to play whatever
you want on the queen side my four
connected BS or five yeah or actually
like seven
yeah I mean and B4 C4 D4 E4 is very
impressive so I mean I could never play
like this with the black because it
doesn't fit my style yes like you got
all this space yaser was very happy
about it yeah I probably yeah he
probably would because he placed the
English with white so MH I mean it takes
certain kinds of players to play the
Kings Indian I don't know where Richie
went wrong maybe it's just slightly
worse the entire game okay Bishop takes
but my first intention was Castle but of
course I missed Bishop E8 and then I
realized that was his plan all along
four Pawn yes mhm and I got Knight
C6 so I spent a long time here but I
also noticed he was getting low on the
clock so I I play Rook C1 I guess white
is slightly
better what do you think was the
critical moment let's say I'm sure there
were a few but let's maybe move to the
to one of those well the first critical
moment was the king's engan then of
course when I played Rook B1 to surprise
yes okay and then I don't know I don't
see how he could have equalized for the
game I mean yeah it's it seems like yeah
I mean you got really good position and
he had to find a ways to equalize and
maybe just didn't happen yeah maybe here
I mean maybe B5 in the computer doesn't
like B5 I suggest suggest F5 I don't
know maybe
here and something like that and then
get he gets counter playay with Queen E8
something uh maybe maybe here like I
wasn't especially pleased with Knight D1
because you're retreating the Knight but
I didn't see any other option I was
going to play here but then the Knight
seems funny on F4 yeah in fact this is
this is very bad yeah so I mean
fortunately I choose the right Square
finally yeah yeah yeah when do you
understand the position is better for
you like you really like felt that yeah
mean it's close to that you have a huge
Advantage already well here I thought I
was slightly better and I was really
maybe Queen C7 Queen B8 not suggested by
the engine maybe this was his best
chance mhm and he's just slightly just
to bring one more piece to the queen
side and and he's just slightly worse
but at the same time that he has to
spend a further Tempo bring the Knight
back to F6 so I was really surprised
when he played E5 mhm no I I was
surprised by many of his moves H5
E5 I guess here I have many attractive
options but I couldn't find a way to
like I was sure I had a big Advantage
here like I could
take but then yeah man I don't know if
this
works C5 Rook d8 Castle Bishop
f8 Rook D1 Bishop C6 I was you were all
culating all this lines yes yeah and the
Knight looks Knight F7 oh my gosh what's
What's Happening Here Yeah I guess
Knight F7 is the only winning move yeah
I was looking at this byc Knight F7
let's move to this moment when yes I
mean this is really interesting land and
probably was also better but you
remember somewhere here uh when he when
you yeah he exchange yes he decided to
go for this exchange sacrifice and he
played this queen H4 do you think that
he wanted to go like Queen H3 after and
then he understood it doesn't give him
much maybe like Queen H3 here but he
went back I think he was just playing
for trick at this point you know as his
as his style he's got very active style
like objectively he has to defend the
passive position yeah yes like mhm like
uh something like this yeah Queen D7
Rook D1 like objectively maybe he had to
defend something like this but it's not
I don't think it's his stle with a bad
Bishop exactly and then let's say the
game yeah we know what happened after
like you just kind of managed to use
your advant the huge Advantage you had
um in thought I was going to go F5 and
then I wasn't sure sure I going to go
something like this yeah wow okay many
many tricks and checks Wesley now
actually I like here I I could I was
thinking to play Knight A5 but I decided
to be courageous once in my life yeah so
I decided to play Rook
C1 fun decided to be brave for once and
I couldn't really see what he was
playing for like uh I guess Queen H3
King F2 I thought he might go Knight F6
at least the queen is but I guess like
how was he been thinking yes so wesle I
mean it was a nice game I mean finally
you won you won it you managed to win
the game and like how do you feel as a
leader of the tournament now well
question I mean I'm glad to win a game
you know finally I thought I would never
win a game again you like no this really
happen thank you so much Wesley and all
the best of luck for you in the next
rounds and now it's time to go for the
commercial break yes thank you thank
you